Okay, here's my answer.
It centers around this SQL statement.
Select * from links where submitter_id = 62443
and votes > 1000.
Those are the constraints of the question.
I make a link just as we've done previously.
I use the fetchone function, and then I return that first link's ID.
Let's give this a run, and we see that the answer is 15,
which is the correct answer.
Now, if you didn't remember that submitter_id is the
is the column name for the user's ID,
you could have found it in a couple of places.
One, you could have looked at the SQL here for creating the table,
and you can see it's called submitter_id.
Or you could have gone up here to the definition of the link class
and guessed that I would have used the same property.
But that's the answer.
Okay, let's get a little fancier with our SQL here.